Donald Trump is continuing his brutal assault
against plumbing and water consumption and
appliances.
The latest is during a rant last night in
Milwaukee.
This is weird.
Donald Trump ranting about dishwashers, uh,
that he clearly does not understand.
I'm going to play the clip and there's a few
funny things here.
First, Trump is again, framing everything
as liberals don't want you to have working
appliances.
We're working to get you good appliances.
The second funny thing is Trump clearly has
no idea how dishwashers work.
I'd be shocked if he ever operated one in
his life.
And number three is his crowds are so clueless
and so willing to be led around by Trump like
they're on a leash that you've even got like
teenagers in the audience cheering about dishwashers.
Can you imagine being 14 and going crazy because
Trump will allow you to buy certain dishwashers
that he claims liberals don't want you to
have.
Take a look at this bizarre clip,
but I'm also approving new dishwashers that
give you more water,
can actually wash and rinse your dishes without
having to do it 10 times or five, six seven
eight nine 10
[inaudible]
I
would bet money Trump has no clue how a dishwasher
works.
But the whole underlying idea again is liberals
want to restrict how much water you can use
and Trump wants to let you use all the water
you want or something like that.
Trump's obsession with plumbing is getting
really weird.
Remember Donald Trump's rant about flushing
toilets 10 to 15 times.
We have a situation where we're looking very
strongly at sinks and showers and other elements
of bathrooms where uh, you turn the faucet
on in areas where there's tremendous amounts
of water where the water rushes out to see
because you could never handle it and you
don't get any water.
You turn on the faucet, you don't get any
water.
They take a shower and water comes dripping
out.
It's dripping out very quietly dripping out.
People are flushing toilets 10 times, 15 times,
as opposed to once they ended up using more
water.
So EPA is looking at that very strongly.
And by suggestion, you go into a new building
or a new house or a new home and they have
standards on where you don't get water, you
can't, you can't wash your hands.
Practically this a little water comes out
of the faucet.
Donald Trump,
the president, most obsessed with plumbing
probably in the history of the United States
during the plumbing era, during the era we're
internal plumbing exists in households.
It's all so bizarre and disjointed and it
is comical to a degree except that he's impeached.
He's wreaking havoc internationally.
He's the laughingstock of the world as we,
uh, played clips for you earlier today.
He's effectively, uh, employing destructive
trade policy while extorting foreign countries
to help him smear his possible opponent in
order to bolster his reelection chances.
If it was only that the guy's whacked out
about plumbing and water, that'd be one thing.
But the water wackiness has happening in addition
to all of these other serious fiascos scandals
and embarrassments.
And it just has to add, I mean we're getting
to the end.
Are we going to have just another year of
this almost to the day, a year and a week
of this, but before we inaugurate someone
else or are we giving this guy an additional
four years?
I'm scared that it's the latter.
I'm hopeful that it's the former, but we've
got to work together to make it happen.